[Musique]
des grands débuts du duo foot tu fais là
l'un en dit long tu fais du skate
alors tu veux faire partie du conseil
départemental des jeunes le coin le
conseil départemental des jeunes
il faut croire c'est l'assemblée des
conseillers départementaux juniors élu
par tous les collégiens de la vienne ok
on t'explique bientôt dans son collège
on va élire une fille et un garçon de
5ème ou de quatrième
ils seront conseiller ou conseillère
départementaux juniors pour deux ans et
c'est quoi un conseiller départemental
un conseiller départemental est élu par
les habitants de la terre
il propose des idées pour la vie
quotidienne les habitants du département
par exemple c'est le conseil
départemental qui décide de faire des
travaux dans nos collèges de construire
un nouveau collège ou de nos équipes en
ordinateurs croît encore l'action
sociale les routes le sport et plein
d'autres choses mais tu ne sait pas
forcément mais je connais rien en route
- ben nous non plus alors qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire
le conseiller départemental junior c'est
pareil sauf qu'il est élu par des jeunes
de la vienne et proposent des idées pour
les jeunes on peut proposer des idées
comme le sport l'environnement la
culture et la vivre ensemble mehdi
ensemble c'est pas par exemple c'est
combattre le racisme à l'école à nous de
trouver des idées pour une fois pour le
nom de notre avis la presse privée oui
il a quant à elle chez free comment tu
dis départemental des jeunes c'est bon
j'ai compris
pas la peine de crier ah ah bah voilà
alors moi c'est bien conseiller
départemental junior mais d'abord il
faut que tu te présentes et que tu es au
moins une idée qui concerne une jeune tu
devra peut-être faire campagne dans ton
collège pour présenter des idées chères
électeurs si je les lectrices alors moi
j'ai des idées mais je suis timide
alors je ne pourrai jamais de conseiller
départemental junior
mais si bien sûr et c'est voilà moi je
pense qu'on devrait réfléchir sur le
harcèlement à l'école
ça nous regarde pas c'est trop compliqué
on y arrive à 10 décembre le début moi
j'ai complètement d'accord laissez le
parler au conseil départemental des
jeunes tout le monde a le droit de
parler et de proposer des idées après on
en discute comment on sera nombreux
cantons se réunira pour parler des
projets il y aura un adulte qui nous
donnera la parole nous aidera dans les
débats et on se réunira régulièrement
pour parler des 4 août m
l'environnement le sport la culture les
vivre ensemble on fera des visites des
rencontres des sorties pour faire
avancer nos projets et on a deux ans
pour les faire aboutir
alors prêt pour les élections au conseil
départemental des jeunes
on a besoin de toi
[Musique]
on